monsieur le président ce que vous
souhaitez pour l'europe
vous affirmez que la france doit
commencer elle même à le faire dès
aujourd'hui votre action en france
raconte une toute autre histoire une
histoire qui met à mal la devise de
votre pays liberté égalité fraternité
[Musique]
où est la liberté lorsque vos citoyens
peuvent être surveillées assigné à
résidence et perquisitionné sur de
simples soupçons de la justice de la
police pardon où est la liberté lorsque
des policiers armés débarquent au petit
matin pour arrêter un groupe de jeunes
dont le seul tort serait d'avoir occupé
pacifiquement un chantier ma fille en
été elle fut emmené devant son fils de
deux ans loin de chez elle pour subir
pendant toute une journée
un interrogatoire dans votre france
l'état de droit garant de nos libertés
s'éloigne jour après jour
liberté égalité ou est-elle l'égalité
lorsque vous imposer toujours plus de
précarité aux travailleurs alors qu'en
même temps vous fait des cadeaux fiscaux
aux plus riches ceux que vous aimez
appelé les premiers de cordée votre foi
en eux tine ébranlable mais voyez-vous
ce qui définit de la corde et monsieur
macron c'est la corde
c'est elle qui permet d'adapter la
vitesse du premier de cordée aux besoins
du groupe 7 et no 6 qui empêche les
dernier de cordée de tomber aura 20 mai
dans nos sociétés monsieur le président
cette corde n'existe plus les riches
s'enrichissent les classes moyennes
stagne et se précarisent et les plus
fragiles sont abandonnés à leur sort
procédure expéditive recours non
suspensif détention administrative voilà
les ingrédients de votre projet de loi
sur l'asile et l'immigration contenir et
refoulé plutôt qu'à cueillir des êtres
humains en exode forcé
monsieur le président vous avez pris
coutume d'offrir à vos hôtes de marque
un cadeau permettez moi de faire de même
je vous offre
cordes d'escaladé symbole de la corde et
à laquelle vous semblez tenir
je vous dirai ceci chaque fois que vous
ferez avancer la cause de la liberté de
l'égalité et de la fraternité en europe
chaque fois que vous agirez pour une re
plus juste plus durable et plus
démocratique
nous serons à vos côtés à défaut vous
nous trouverez sur votre route je vous
remercie
[Musique]
c'est précisément parce que ici je suis
avec en effet la légitimité du peuple
français mais avec toute l'exigence de
celui ci que je ne peux pas accepter les
propos que vous avez tenus sur ce qui se
passe dans mon pays
le premier pour vous dire que il y a une
constitution en pays qui n'a pas attendu
pour intégrer les libertés fondamentales
une déclaration des droits de l'homme un
préambule de 46 et qui a intégré toutes
ces valeurs et dia un conseil
constitutionnel pour juger et savoir si
les lois respecte la liberté l'égalité
de la fraternité les lois dont vous avez
parlé
le conseil constitutionnel que ce soit
parfait zine des parlementaires ou par
question préjudicielle pour la loi
sécurité intérieure et lutte contre le
terrorisme les a jugés et donc vous
pouvez tenir des propos d'estrade
ils peuvent vous allez monsieur parce
que vous avez le confort de ce salon
mais moi je n'ai pas le confort de ce
lieu et j'ai la cohésion j'ai eu la
courtoisie
j'ai eu la courtoisie de vous écouter je
vous demande la même courtoisie su cette
courtoisie qui est démocratique
vous êtes un représentant je suis un
autre représentant mais la loi sécurité
intérieure lutte contre le terrorisme
elle permet de lutter contre les
terroristes islamistes dans notre pays
c'est à ce titre qu'elle permet des
visites domiciliaires
c'est à ce titre qu'elle permet en effet
la protection des espaces publics je
l'assumé totalement
parce que je suis aujourd'hui le
président d'un pays à de multiples
reprises attaqué par des terroristes et
je ne saurais expliquer à mon peuple que
nous désarmons face à ce risque parce
que des gens comme vous je permettent de
proférer des contre vérités au nom des
principes qui sont ancrées dans notre
république est descendu par le conseil
constitutionnel et que portent toutes un
parlement et au nom du respect que j'ai
pour la majorité au parlement comme pour
le conseil je ne peux vous laisser dire
les bêtises pardonnez-moi de ce terme
que vous avez ainsi préféré